So you're about to start a family
or you've already started one.
Having a child is a beautiful,
transcendent experience
but you're also gonna
find yourself asking,
"How much is this going to cost me?"
I like him holding up this notebook.
This episode is personal to me.
Bobby here was born last year
and I often look at him
and I wonder what the future holds,
not just for him
but for me and my wallet.
What does daycare cost?
What do diapers cost?
Does he need a college fund?
It's pretty daunting to
add all that stuff up
but Cristina Livadary has
actually crunched the numbers.
Cristina, thank you so much
for being on "Good Money".
I just had a baby, he's nine months old,
so we're kind of going through this.
There's figures out there
that most people get
about what having a kid costs.
And you kind of delved into that
and saw that, saw what
the truth was, I suppose.
It really does vary
and depend upon a number of factors.
So a great cost that can vary a lot
is the cost of maternity healthcare.
On average, Americans can expect to spend
if they're covered by
a health plan, $4,500
for routine maternity healthcare.
That doesn't include, you know,
if you have an emergency C-section
or if you have a longer than
expected stay in the NICU.
So $4,500 is really just
the base starting point.
The next thing we wanted
to investigate was
what we call "getting
ready for baby" costs.
How much are we going to spend
on getting that nursery ready?
Most of our clients spend about $5,000
for some of those bigger items
that don't get bought
during the baby shower.
So that could be your crib,
your bassinet, your stroller.
It's worth mentioning,
the Baby Care Products market
is projected to be worth
over $100 billion worldwide by 2025.
You could do parental or birthing classes
so that's like $650.
That's, like, on average
for one of those classes
but there's also doulas
and lactation consultants.
On average is about $2,500 for either
that lactation consultant and/or doula.
So then the final part, the
most you'll spend on your child,
is childcare.
The cost of childcare is enormous.
Very early on, if you decide
and you have the means
to do a night nurse,
that night nurse in LA can range anywhere
from $30 to $40 an hour.
And then you have just basic childcare
so whether it's infant daycare, a nanny
and especially popular here in Los Angeles
is having an au pair
and so an au pair will
cost you $20,000 a year.
But the other thing is that
they'll also have to live with you.
So if you add all those up,
it comes to a grand total of $47,000.
Ooh, yeah.
Gosh.
That's the cost of having a baby right now
but what about the future?
Are they going to go to
college? Trade school?
When are they going to move
out of the house? Ever?
Roger Ma's a Certified Financial Planner
and he's been thinking
about this stuff a lot
especially since he has a
baby of his own named, Owen.
Both of them joined us to talk.
Let me just start by saying,
I haven't done anything
to prepare for Bobby's financial future.
I'm starting at zero.
What can I do today to
make that a rosier picture?
It's always good to get a sense
of where you're starting from.
So I think
coming up with your financial report card
which includes calculating your net worth,
figuring out what your
living expenses are,
how much you spend on a monthly basis.
Yeah, Owen.
And in what categories
and then also what your
credit score is as well
and I think that's a great starting point.
Is saving for college
as big of a deal now,
as it used to be?
The cost of education has been increasing
substantially year after year
but honestly, I don't think we really know
what the, what form higher education
is gonna take in 15, 20 years.
And if it's gonna be as important in terms
of employers using it for signaling
so I certainly recommend
to save within a 529 plan.
A 529 plan is a tax
advantage savings account
designed to be used for a
beneficiary's education expenses,
like Bobby's.
Let's say I do a 529 plan
and he grows up
and he's like, "I don't
want to go to college."
What happens to that money?
Yeah, so usually if you are taking it out
for non-eligible expenses,
you might get taxed at
your federal tax rate,
state tax, it might be
subject to local tax too
and then you might pay a penalty as well.
That said, I think it's also
important to save within,
say a Roth IRA or a
taxable brokerage account.
Money in those accounts
is a little more flexible
than money in a 529 plan.
Are education expenses...
What does that include?
So I believe it includes
room, board, tuition,
certain electronic expenses, like computer
and some other technology.
Uh-huh.
There's some flexibility
to change beneficiary
on the account so certainly
you might intend to use it
for Bobby's educational expenses
but let's say he goes to college,
you still have money left
and you want to take
an a class for yourself
and it's at an eligible institution.
You could change the
beneficiary to yourself.
I think the other two things,
that would be helpful
to get into place are
a term life insurance policy
outside of your employer coverage
and then making sure that you
have an estate plan in place.
And if you already have one in place,
updating it to incorporate your little one
and particularly, not only,
figuring out where your stuff goes
but in the case where you're not around
and your partner isn't around,
who is going to take care of Bobby?
So start a 529 plan,
get a term life insurance
policy outside of my employer
and change my estate plan
or will to include Bobby.
All right, so I'm starting to feel better
now that I know the cost,
it's probably going to be in the tens
of thousands of dollars.
This is information that
I wish I'd had a while ago
and that I hope that
he has someday as well.
Unfortunately, he's probably
not going to learn this
in our traditional school system.
The best example's gonna
be learning from you.
How does one teach kids
to have a good relationship with money?
Even if you don't feel like
you have a great relationship with money,
you have a good understanding
of your own money situation.
Sharing your money ideas
and any experiences with money.
Money is in every facet of our life,
going to the grocery
store, driving our cars,
living in our houses.
So being open and honest
with our children,
when you're making a grocery list
and going and looking at the ads
to see what's on sale this week.
When you're talking about
doing chores in the house,
if you're going to give an allowance.
And why we would be doing
that for our children,
like, "Why we're giving
you the allowance."
And just leading by example
and not being afraid of your
own insecurities around money
because those are going to
transpose onto your children.
What would you suggest
is like a proper amount
to divulge about, you know,
income,
comfort?
Just being more open,
even if it's like
possibly negative things.
Telling your kids, "We don't
have enough money for that."
Or, "Remember we want to go
and take this vacation next month
so this month we're not
going to go out to dinner
or we're not going to
go to Chuck E. Cheese
or to the movies,
we're gonna try to save our money
because we want to have money for next,
our next trip or next month."
And just explaining that
process to children,
what's actually going on in your head,
I think is very helpful
because a lot of times they don't see it.
They don't understand how
the money even comes in,
why daddy goes to work,
why mommy goes to work,
that putting gas in the car costs money,
sometimes they don't even
see those transactions.
So allowing them to see those transactions
is always very helpful.
So we talked about expenses, planning
and teaching your kids about money.
Now, I hope that the school system starts
to make financial education
a little bit more commonplace
but until then,
we're going to have to
just do it ourselves.